a congregation of millions
for this once in 12-year hindu festival
of the mahakuma
devotees have descended from all parts
of the country on the banks of the river
ganga
for a holy tip all this amidst a raging
pandemic
india now records the highest number of
daily cases in the world
and is second only to the united states
with over 13.5 million cases
the festival allowed by the hindu
nationalist party
of prime minister modi has come under
severe criticism
millions of pilgrims from all corners of
the country are here health experts have
flagged this as a super spreader
as it's impossible to implement any
corvette restrictions
in this large crowd the reality is that
the administration
is struggling
there is a rush to reach the main banks
before the auspicious time
passes the police are overwhelmed
saraswati and her husband have traveled
hundreds of miles from rajasthan
for many weeks the country has been
immersed in state elections
the prime minister his cabinet and
leaders of all political parties
are campaigning at rallies with
thousands in attendance
wrote shows by politicians expose every
nook
and corner india's vaccination process
started slow but has picked up base
there is a long way to go as less than
one percent of the population
have completed their full dose
[Music]
events like these could be avoided at a
time when the country is in the grip
of a deadly second wave
the rising numbers do not bode well for
a nation
which has poor public health facilities
and services
never lazarus sky news haridwar